الرئيس والسيدة الأولى يلقيان
نظرة وجها لوجه على الحزن والصدمة
في الجاموس ما حدث هنا
هو إرهاب إرهابي بسيط ومباشر
إرهاب محلي تأتي زيارتهما في الوقت الذي
تظهر فيه تفاصيل جديدة حول
المنشورات على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي للمسلح المتهم بالتفصيل
تفاعل بيتون غندرون مع  المحققين
في يونيو 2021 بعد إشارة مشؤومة
إلى الانتحار بالقتل ، قام
بالتهديد أثناء حضوره مدرسة سسكويهانا
فالي الثانوية في كونكلين نيويورك ،
تحدثنا إلى المدعي العام
لمقاطعة مسقط رأسه حول ذلك في فصل عبر الإنترنت
قال للمدرس إنه كان كذلك
أثناء التفكير في جريمة قتل وانتحار ،
تابع المعلم ذلك ،
وأشار المشتبه فيه إلى أنه كان
يمزح فقط في منشور كتب عام أنه تم
إرساله إلى المستشفى لإجراء تقييم عقلي
ولكنه استمر 15 دقيقة فقط من
الاقتباس لأنني تمسكت بالقصة
التي  كنت أخرج من الفصل ،
وكتبت بغباء أن هذا
هو السبب في أنني أعتقد أنني ما زلت قادرًا على
شراء الأسلحة  لم تكن مزحة لقد كتبت
ذلك لأن هذا ما كنت
أخطط للقيام به على الرغم من هذا الحادث
، سُمح للجندرون بشراء أسلحة نارية
بموجب القانون الفيدرالي ، يقول د.
حصلت الشرطة على أن شرطة الولاية
متورطة ، حيث قامت شرطة ولاية نيويورك التي
تحدثت معه بنقله إلى
مستشفى محلي لإجراء تقييم نفسي
، تم تبرئته وإطلاق سراح الجندرون ، وأصدر
بيانًا من 180 صفحة
يوضح بالتفصيل مجموعة من الأسلحة النارية التي كان بحوزته ،
بما في ذلك جيش معدل بشكل غير قانوني
- بندقية من طراز زُعم أنه استخدمها
في هجوم يوم السبت وبندقية يقول
أن والده اشتراها له ،
وتقول الوثيقة إنه خطط لاستخدام البندقية
وبندقية الصيد لمواصلة استهداف
السود في أماكن أخرى من الجاموس إذا لم يتم
إيقافه في السوبر ماركت.  ألقى باللوم على
الجميع
في حدوث ذلك واستمرار
حدوثه لمجتمعاتنا ،
وتقول الشرطة إن المسلح أطلق النار على أربعة أشخاص
في ساحة انتظار وتبادل إطلاق النار
مع  حارس أمن وأطلق النار على المزيد من
الأشخاص في المتجر قبل الاستسلام
الليلة ، نسمع أيضًا المزيد
من زملائي السابقين في Gendron
يصفونه بأنه وحيد ، لقد منحني شعورًا غريبًا
في بطني لسبب
ما لا أعرف لماذا أعني أنه كان كذلك  لطيف
لكنه كان خجولًا حقًا ، هل شعرت
أنه ربما كان عنصريًا أو
هل شعرت أنه ربما كان
غريبًا أو غريبًا أو زاحفًا أو
غريبًا في الغالب غريبًا في بعض الأحيان أعني
أنني لا أحب أن أحكم على الناس ولكن هذا
هو الانطباع  ما حصل منه هو
أسلوبه في الكلام أو الأشياء التي
قال أنها أعطتك ذلك ، لأنه لم
يتصل بي بالعين عندما تحدثت
أنه نظر حولي